she's a smoke show okay
uh have you seen anything about this the
ncaa
apologized recently because a tick tock
went viral
of i believe she plays on the oregon
women's basketball
team and she recorded what the girl's
weight
lifting room looked like versus the guys
weightlifting room and it started a lot
of controversy because on one hand
there were people like steph curry who
called out the ncaa saying that
it's wrong it's unequal and then there's
people like swaggy p
nikki young coming out saying well
you're the jv league like you don't
bring in the type of money that
the boys say i got hats
hackers swag
and then um ncaa came out and said that
they apologized for what happened and
that the girls didn't have space
yeah in their facility to hold that type
of equipment
she made an updated tick tock saying we
have more than enough space
this is stupid oh she lied no no no no
no
so for the ncaa march madness the
biggest tournament
in college basketball for women this is
our weight room
let me show you all the men's weight
room
that looks pretty sick now our weight
room got released versus the men's the
ncaa came out with a statement saying
that it wasn't money
it was space that was a problem let me
show y'all something else
here's our practice court right and then
here's that weight room
and then this extra
space if you are upset about this
problem then you're a part of it
i got something i got a question here's
where it gets dicey
go on
all right do me a favor how many people
watch women's march madness last year
well that shouldn't mean they shouldn't
have gym like a dope gym
well hold on hold on let's hold on
it's easy to say how are they gonna have
the same dope gym let's say you're
running the ncaa
okay you're on the ncaa well there was
no march madness last year do 2019
viewership
2000 oh so but there was no men's right
2019 there it is
i think a big issue with this i saw
somebody talk about this on twitter
in the ncaa rules men and women
regardless of how much money they bring
in
have to have the same yeah that's
unrealistic hey so go
so seven point three million now go to
the men's how many people watch the
men's march matches oh i know
i'm in there the title game is the 2019
sure ten
point nine other was three mm-hmm not
seven seven seven
so it's not that much that sounds higher
the problem is to be fair uh somebody
released a statistic of how much it
costs
to fund the women's team every single
year and it was a few million versus how
much they brought in
it barely it was a fraction of what they
actually bring in whereas the men's
was very profitable so you do have a
point there where like yeah
it's like it's not that it shouldn't be
equal they should definitely have a
weight room like obviously nc don't be
[ __ ] up yeah but if i'm running a
business
so you know if i'm running a business
let's say
let's say my business was based off
instagram followers and that's
cat and chin and cat has 10 000
followers and chin has a million
and i'm a business and i'm running ads
and chins bring in
100 a million dollars a month okay and
cats bring in 10
000 a month and cat goes i want a car
chin goes i want a car
i'll probably give chin a better car
because he's bringing in money so
it makes sense to give chin the better
car opposed to cat even though she's a
woman
it's not a fact that she's a woman he's
a man it's the fact that
he brings in 100 you're going off no she
brings in yeah
but we make it this this you know sex
thing you know women deserve this
and it's like i'm not even saying that
same with like wnba
you're mad how many people watch how
many people watch your game
now that is is that a is that whose
problem is that
what why do people prefer to watch men's
mba than women's wnb
uh because then well again i hate the
the knack that they say women's women's
basketball is more skilled
but it's some skills exactly but you
that's the narrative they put out there
but again men's basketball is
entertaining but but again
if i'm a business that me brings in how
many viewers
where's the women what does the w nba
bring in
their biggest games are the finals so if
you go wa uh but they're all 2019
finals but their finals are not fair
because they're on their finals are the
same
time that the nba finals are on no
there's there's a
later no it's a little bit it's funny
there's after
yeah like september i don't know so
allergens 750
000 viewers 5 i'm sorry 570 000 okay
now go to the uh the men's nba 220
finals
8.8 million uh it says
15 15 million average was 80 million
high was 15. so the women's high was
what
500. 570 thousand men's was 15 million
[Music]
what do you want i mean what do you want
to do dude advertisers pay
whoever those advertisers don't give a
[ __ ] if it's man or woman they just want
eyeballs so i have tires not going oh
yeah because they're women we don't want
to work with them they go no
we want to be in front of 50 million
people yeah so it's tough now granted
ncaa [ __ ] up those women should have a
proper facility
like that's right that's that's all i'm
saying i'm like why can't they just like
now
at least the problem should be the same
facility as the men yeah
somebody's saying but why i can't have a
collab a joint like when it was just at
least
something better i shouldn't just have
those dumbbells yeah that's just
insulting
yeah yeah they got those dumbbells from
the liquid because if i had a daughter
i'd be [ __ ]
furious yeah like i like like i'm not
talking about like the viewership or
anything like that
i'm just saying like a [ __ ] weight
facility
that is at least like you know proper
and accommodating and better
see this this is what's weird it goes
from what i've been showing it pairs of
swag bags where the men receive
are much more substantial than the
women's as well
again more there's more revenue there's
more ads so they have the the
ability to put up the money for that
yeah so it's not a man or woman thing
it's a money thing
i know i know a couple of ways so what
so basically the ncaa has this budget
they're like okay
here's our budget for this and that's
how they map it out yep
i know a couple of ways that that can
get viewers to watch the wnba
wmeb easy now tread lightly bubble okay
what'd you say i know a couple of ways a
lot of people
say lower the rim and all that but lower
the rim you know
so what is it what is their rim it's the
same as means
it has to be oh it's ten feet yeah lower
the rim
lower the rim just cool really
really keep really ready yeah you lower
the rim you're going to have more fights
it's going to be entertaining there's no
more layups that jim that women
insulting
it is just four dumbbells like nah you
got this
bro they're gonna hold those dogs get
creative ladies yeah get creative come
on ncaa
at least at least try a little that's
what i know they don't bring in the same
money but jesus christ man
the highest like that but that was
that's legit they're what they gave them
yeah that's ridiculous
that's what i'm saying i'm like you
could do better
way better than be a little less obvious
than that and 12 yoga mats
like this will stay like that like
that's listen i understand viewership
stats blah blah blah yeah yeah you know
give a girl a medicine ball
or at least let them like because here's
the other here's the other argument too
it's like
you know those universities make so much
[ __ ] money whether it's men or women
they make
so much money you could give them a
better job yeah i mean
like you know being cheerleaders we were
allowed to use you know
something funny y'all no dude no what
are you doing
what you were saying what you're staying
good i'm sorry i was laughing at that
you know lord of the rib i was laughing
at that
go ahead bro your cheerleaders you did
you guys get equal rights
do you guys have to drink from a
separate fountain how does that work
with cheerleaders
they gave you weighted pom-poms no he
was like like we would use the same
[ __ ] but it was
it was after they were done last night
that is not what the hell i'm saying
what i'm saying is like we would get
their gatorade if they were finished
with it
i love like 86. they would let us use
the penalty
colorado the [ __ ] the cheerleaders
no the cheerleaders would use the gym
but it'd be like yeah
they're like they're like like you know
they're telling you brothers
facilities for cheerleaders at certain
colleges are dope as [ __ ] like big time
uh oklahoma state the cowboys yeah
kansas too yeah yeah
texas tech they have gopass facilities i
go to the games just to watch that they
made so much money they could definitely
apply that's what i'm saying why
couldn't they even do that dude
ncaa is the biggest [ __ ] scam in the
world you wanna talk about a corrupt
business model brothers talk kids over
there nice they don't
have nothing they pay them nothing
nothing and take all the money
all the money and then they go oh we're
doing education and no they're battling
them
[ __ ] them the ball games they're do
you think athletes should be paid
100 yes tim tebow when he's playing had
the number one selling jersey over
lebron james you know what he made for
that
zero and then he went all to florida
when he was in college yes
he was that famous definitely you know
how much money he got zero
florida new jersey florida took all the
money that had his name
yeah i know yeah i know i know his thing
okay yeah
really yeah bro let's talk about it ncaa
video games
he had his face on the cover have the
video games yeah they don't get money
from that
ask them how much but now they there's a
license deal where they give them some
percentage but
not a lot but it's a slap it's not right
yeah because they keep because their
thing is
because they give you a free call
they're like you got a free education
like [ __ ] you made me major in
communications i can't use this
yeah yeah he's using it i'm using it and
you're communicating
exactly it's it's all [ __ ] up i mean
i know it's like super effective yeah
like when oklahoma or ohio state goes to
a bowl game
okay they get like 40 million dollars
and i'm like we're giving these kids
40 minutes to school the school it goes
back to now yeah
so if a team that why do you think
college was like
frantic about figuring out how to play
during covet because
and he's corrupt that's why the pac-12
is [ __ ] it's mostly because they were
[ __ ]
because they were the only ones i wasn't
playing yeah so everyone's transferring
and now they don't have money
so they're cutting stamford wrestling
even though they have a national
champion
like they don't have money because these
[ __ ] morons were the only conferences
i didn't know it was like that it's the
most corrupt business model in the world
yeah damn and they have women's
basketball
and the story i want to declare those
women should have a better course that's
you they should have if i'm a
businessman i'm like all right let's
let's
take out don't don't better than that
don't don't get wrong this should be
better than that but
the same thing if i'm a owner of the nba
team wnba team and i'm going through
taxes
and i don't know men or women i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on here
well i'm i don't want to be part of that
no don't give them a two million dollar
locker room you know yeah
and someone's like oh those are women
like i don't care all i care about is my
bottom dollar
that's how that's what they're thinking
got it and if i was a businessman i'd
say lower the rim i'm tired of watching
skillful layups
get dunked on sorry brenda no i'm with
you
what else you got oh how about that when
i get off stage with the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son